par exemple touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé entre
2012 et 2017 a été auditionné durant
deux heures par la commission d' enquête
parlementaire
elle a défendu son bilan selon ai
toujours voulu garder un très haut
niveau de stocks de masques 750 millions
en l'occurrence et ce malgré une
doctrine qui n'était qu'un avis en 2011
puis est devenue une directive en 2013
qui conseillait de sortir de la logique
de ce taux comme macif pour une logique
de flux mais marisol touraine ne le
souhaitait pas elle a donc continuer à
stocker du groupe aux de l'écouteur j'ai
maintenu l'idée qu'il fallait avoir des
stocks importants à seulement pour les
masquer je vais revenir dans un instant
et c'est la raison pour laquelle même si
certains d'entre vous vont dire mais
pourquoi n'y avait il pas un milliard de
masques kenyan n'a investi que 754
millions il y avait 7 154 millions de
masques à la fin du mandat
mais lorsqu'elle nièces cousins a pris
ses fonctions et bien très rapidement
elle se serait aperçu que les stocks
étaient périmés ou inexistants elle a
donc recommandé mais les stocks n'ont
jamais été reconstitué à la hauteur des
précédents
et puis pourquoi n'at-elle pas su que
ces stocks étaient périmés et bien il ya
un problème de remontée d'informations
marisol touraine
jacques elle avait une délégation qui la
tenait au courant très précisément de la
quantité de masques nous avons posé la
question et nous sommes forgés qui
députés présents à cette commission sur
la question des remontées d'informations
au sein des ministères puisque le fait
du masque sa pose à moi je crois un
problème de comment fonctionnent nos
administrations publiques
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans la remontée
d'informations pourquoi est ce que tout
le monde n'est pas collectivement au
courant d'un élément important qui a un
coût financier qui a un coût humain
potentiel sa pelouse plutôt un problème
de qu'est-ce que c'est la logistique
d'êta qu'est-ce que celle que la
communication dans un cabinet
ministériel ou entre peut-être trop de
couches administrative trop agences et
il ya un ministère et le ministre ça
pose plutôt la question profonde de
l'organisation française des structures
d'état française
et là je pense qu'il ya en effet des
redondances qui font qu'il ya des
messages qui reste on va se clôt lieu
d'être diffusées largement roselyne
bachelot ancienne ministre de la santé
et des sports entre 2007 et 2010 a
ensuite été auditionné on se souvient
qu'elle avait été critiqué pour ses
commandes jugées excessives de masques
et de vaccins durant l'épidémie de h1n1
eh bien il est resté modeste elle a
expliqué que le contexte à l'époque
lutte est bien plus favorable qu'au
moment du corona virus il se trouve
qu'elle a multiplié les salves contre
tout et tout le monde c'est à dire la
france un pays infantiliser les conseils
départementaux l'opinion publique
certains professionnels de santé mais
elle a aussi répondu à une question clé
concernant la gestion par un ministre
évidemment on pense à agnès buzyn est ce
qu'être ministre c'est être au courant
de tout et bien selon roselyne bachelot
oui quand on est en charge d'un ministre
on doit tout connaître bien sûr